every kid absolutely loves Minecraft and
you wrote this book it's a terrific idea
and I'm actually when I got a copy this
book today I thought I'm taking his home
to my son who's 11 and he loves
minecraft and this is about someone
waking up in the world of Minecraft
that's right yeah they this is this is a
world where the person essentially is
like Robinson Crusoe
because what's so great about Minecraft
is that it's actually a guide for life
that's what I learned playing it with my
son I learned oh my god
if played right if played on survival it
teaches you patience and planning and
how to recover from failure it's
everything a parent should want so when
I was approached and they said do you
have a take on a Minecraft book I was
like are you kidding oh my god this is
the guide to life so minecraft the
island okay now you have a son and he
likes minecraft right okay I would think
that he would now consider you a god
because yeah his dad wrote the book
about Minecraft wouldn't that put you at
godlike status for I mean I know that if
I did that my son would have to respect
me finally yeah you would you would
think yeah you would think I I thought
okay this is it this is I'm finally to
get the dad points that I deserve yes I
didn't tell him I was writing it it was
a completely you kept it a secret I
thought oh I'm gonna blow his mind
yes so writing it in secret and then I
say to him one weekend I go hey I took
to go just go out to lunch he goes yeah
sure
I took him to minecon 15,000 people in
one room and suddenly now I should say I
should preface this by saying my wife
has gone for the weekend friend's
wedding boss and I go no no go it's
father-son time yeah yeah here were you
at a plan oh did I have a plan so I'm
there and suddenly we're mine Connie's
excited and then they start reading he
goes what are they reading from I go my
book and I get up on stage and I say
I've written this minecraft book and I
wrote it for you son this is for you and
we go home and that night he gets a
nosebleed and he goes oh I wish mom was
here this is the worst weekend
that wind is so true to me
you